in this final segment we want to discuss
an interesting point about linear
estimators here's what the issue is you
obtain an observation X on the basis of
which you want to estimate theta but
perhaps you measure X on a different
scale let's say on a cubic scale so that
what you record actually is X cube so
you're faced with two possible
estimation problems one estimation
problem is to use X to estimate theta
another estimation problem is to use X
cube to estimate theta does it make a
difference let us consider the case of
least mean squares estimation without
any linearity constraint if you use X to
estimate theta your estimator is going
to be this conditional expectation if
you use X cube to estimate theta your
estimator will be this conditional
expectation are they different well X
and X cube carry the same information
about theta in particular the posterior
distribution of theta given X is going
to be the same as the posterior
distribution of theta given X cube you
will be getting the same information the
same knowledge about X and in particular
if you calculate conditional
expectations these will also be the same
what about the linear case if we
restrict to linear estimators then on
the basis of X you would form a linear
estimation of this kind but if your
observation is in the form of X cube
then a linear estimator would form a
linear function of X cube so this would
be a different kind of estimator we have
seen a formula on how to obtain the best
estimator the best choices of a and B
for estimators of this kind we can use
that same formula to obtain the best
estimator of that kind it's going to be
of course a different estimator here
we're optimizing within a different
class which one of the two is better
well this depends on what you know about
the particular problem at hand if you
have some reason to believe or if you
know that theta and X are roughly
related by some kind of cubic relation
then perhaps estimators in this class
are going to perform better than
estimators in that class let me also
point out a related issue that would
come here to find the right choice of a
you need to know the covariance between
X and theta that's what the formula
tells us about the optimal linear
estimator here you would need to know
the covariance between theta and X cube
in addition the formula requires the
variance of X but here instead of X were
using X cube so in this case we would
need the variance of X cube now this
could be more challenging in general the
higher the powers that you have the more
difficult these quantities are to
calculate or to know what they are but
leaving that issue aside what we have
here is two alternative choices for the
structure of the estimator that we are
using now we can push this story further
instead of considering just estimators
of this kind we might consider as well
estimators of this kind is this a linear
estimator we still call it a linear
estimator because it is linear in the
coefficients that we have to choose on
how to optimize that's the more
important part it's the linearity in
these coefficients that's important
rather than the linearity in the axis so
as a function of X is this is nonlinear
on the other hand we can think of this X
as one observation x squared as another
observation X cube as a third
observation and what we got here is a
linear function of three different
observation
so we can still pose a least squares
problem in which we try to find the best
choices for the coefficients a1 a2 and
a3 as well as the coefficient B find
those choices that are going to give us
the smallest possible mean squared error
so we can optimize within this class
within this class of estimators we
certainly have more flexibility this is
a more general class of estimators on
either this one or that one
so within this class we should be able
to do even better on the other hand we
will have to pay a price that this is a
more complex structure it will be more
difficult to find the optimal
coefficients and also we're going to
need higher order moments or
expectations related to the X's and the
Thetas finally there's nothing special
in us using powers of X and using a
polynomial we could also look at
estimators that have some other type of
structure for example we might want to
mix an exponential function in X and the
logarithmic function of X look at
estimators of this form and try to
choose the best one find the best choice
of the coefficients again this is
something that is possible and again
it's going to boil down to solving a
system of linear equations in the
coefficients on the other hand we need
to know various expectations about X
that might be difficult to obtain how do
we choose which structure to use should
it be this one this one this one or that
one there's a trade-off that more
complicated structures introduce more
complexity and make the problem more
difficult but there's also another issue
it has to do with what we know about the
particular problem at hand if we know or
have reason to believe that third order
polynomials are going to give us
excellent estimates of theta then we may
want to work with in this class in any
case the moral of the story is that if
we are to use the linear estimation
methodology we
do have some choices linear in what and
different choices will give us different
performance but this now gets some words
away from the subject of mathematical
methodology and it gets closer to the
art that you need to exercise in any
particular problem domain